feeling lazy  corny  unnecessary  not the life of the party  we'll feel that way no longer  [Music]  [Applause]  try the new black power bars black power  bars are four inches longer than your  average power bar and they consist of  three key ingredients  protein to help you build up muscle  [Music]  flavor unlike those boring ass white  power bars  and last but not least energy  to help you run away from all the  [ __ ] life throws your way like  hatred discrimination segregation  depression  white women clutching their purses  you put their cigarette out in my  corvacie how many more times do i have  to take this woman out before i get to  hit that and many more  so try our new black power bars and no  longer be a slave to laziness  not responsible for police harassment or  retired or being looked down and shunned  out by society